what we're about to do right now is
we're gonna set up fliers inform people
about ice agents and the rights in case
ice agents come to a person's house
never open your door you have the right
to like not incriminate yourself if you
are undocumented these children are
becoming experts at what to do if an
immigration or ice officer wants to talk
to them their New York neighborhood was
targeted in raids last weekend part of
Donald Trump's push to find and deport
some of America's 11 million
undocumented immigrants I'm terrified
personally my mom is undocumented I have
younger siblings I have an older brother
who can't really take care of himself
I'm personally terrified of the fact
that I might have to lose my mom soon
it's getting wild over here it's like
you don't know where to go people are
telling you different things like you'd
like my mom personally told me not to go
out like the whole weekend - if it's not
for school reasons or Club reasons I
shouldn't be going out at all close by
at the immigrant support center people
are queuing out of the door to get
passports and documents in order
should they be deported to home
countries many have been here for
decades but fear things are changing in
Trump's America
aracely unwilling to be identified and
speaking with translation help describes
how her son was abused while traveling
to work an African American on the train
just yelling him that he's of immigrant
discrimination what we going to do now
what I want to happen now the
fundamentals of this country's in
immigrants but now immigrants are now
welcoming this country people are scared
to go everywhere to go to a church to go
to school just to go to work darrel
scary the US government says fears are
exaggerated of the nearly 700 people
arrested in recent raids across the
country the vast majority had committed
serious crimes
Isis described its enforcement
operations in neighborhoods like this
one as both routine and targeted with a
focus on people who threaten Public
Safety like gang members as well as
those who've already been deported and
re-entered the country illegally I
should not be picking up people at
schools hospitals and religious
institutions still community activists
are preparing for the raids to intensify
and their scope broaden in this training
session they discussed setting up rapid
text alerts and creating networks of
safe houses to shelter the vulnerable
all the while resentment is building
Donald Trump and his administration have
based their immigration policy on lies
that immigrants create crimes that
immigrants take jobs that immigrants
suck up public resources every single
one of those is a lie in the face of
almost constant protests Trump is
unmoved he is doing exactly what he
promised he would enforcing the law of a
country whose people elected him
president Hanna taught Peter Sky News in
New York